one of the reasons i went to get the
ketamine therapy is because i didn't
know why i'm still
on antidepressants it's like one of the
weirdest medicines that
you know i was having a tough time when
i was like 20 and i went in
they put it on they put me on it or i
agreed to be on it you know i i mean i
took part in it and
and then now 20 years later i'm still on
it so it's kind of like
like if you broke your leg you wouldn't
have a cast on forever probably so some
of that to me is like
what's going on here like is this
something i need to be on forever so
that's one of the reasons that i went in
probably to check it out you know i wish
i'd
had a better i was in there with a
therapist and i
i think they were just more of like
there if i had an
issue um i sometimes wish that somebody
would have been
like prodding me more or telling me
how to it's almost like when you go
snorkeling that's what it kind of felt
like a little bit
it was like i'm looking at
a lot was going on you know if i felt
like i'm a roller coaster i'm on a
roller coaster i felt like
the world is kind i felt like i was on
space mountain sometimes with my eyes
closed you know just kind of like moving
through like
did you have the round shapes or the
square shapes
i mean i i mean i think there was a turf
war going on because there was a lot of
there was some real i think it was a lot
of shapes out there
you know it was definitely like somebody
was um
i mean i remember one time literally
yelling out that i was a cryptocurrency
i thought i was
like i went it got pretty gnarly you
know like it got pretty gnarly like i
remember one time thinking
there's no way i'm going to end up back
in my chair in this therapist office i
don't know how i'm going to get there
from where i am yeah i had some fun
you know so that kind of stuff was kind
of exciting and i think sometimes i got
too
caught looking at the the the experience
and not using the experience right so
that's why i wish that
there had been more before i went in to
get it that i had had more of an
understanding of
how to navigate the universe a little
bit and how to use the experience
yeah um because that i that i didn't
have
and that is sort of like
um you can do a lot more with
ketamine assisted psychotherapy you can
use that place you're in
to visit the pain
that has brought you to this distress
state
yeah there was a moment i remember there
was a moment where i got to see my dad
be around my dad right
and i'd never my dad died when i was
like 16 and he was really older man
he was 86 when he passed away and and i
was 16 so he was older when i was born
he was an adult you know
he was senior citizen but um
i got to have like this experience
around him and it was like a real
like it felt like i was around him and
i got to let him i i got to
you know i felt like my dad never knew
how much i loved him i felt like i had
just never gotten to an
age where i could tell him that i loved
him you know
and i didn't realize how much that was
kind of haunting me i think somewhere
inside of me
you know like um yeah exactly i just
never
knew like that that was such a big thing
going on underneath me somewhere
and uh and i literally got to have
a moment or a little bit a couple
moments with him
in a emotional state kind of it felt
like anyway to me it felt very real to
me that i was letting him know
uh how much i loved him yeah
and that and that's priceless because
there's no there was no other way to do
that i mean
there may there may have been but i i
hadn't found that yet
yeah that that is like
core to what um
ketamine is psychotherapy gives people
access to it's like
those little gaps those little holes in
our heart that
that happen to us when we're young shape
a lot of our life and so to be able to
reach back in time
and and find yourself then and there and
that
that sort of that grief pain
of separation that you you didn't get to
have with him
you could connect to yourself and and
sort of complete
almost in a way like the grieving
process so you could release
that tension from yourself yeah that
that distress that's
that's like that's in there and it's
always in there and it's
you don't know how to get it out and
you're pushing through
life and a couple decades go by and
you're like
i'm still haunted by things and some
people are not
able to even see some of those things it
felt really intimate
you know i remember i mean right when i
started to go under i just started
tears just like rolled out of my eyes
you know like i don't even know what was
going on really you know
i think it could have just been like i
mean me i'm always probably 30
sad so who knows what it was you know
but um
but i remember just being pretty
emotional right out of the gate and the
first day i was dehydrated
literally just from like crying i think
half of the whole session like
and some of it i didn't realize i was
crying like i didn't even really feel it
because i was kind of also
you get kind of you're kind of
anesthetized in a way
so the main part of me that's still
awake is kind of this
kind of that all-knowing place inside of
your head where you have ideas and stuff
you know
yeah like whenever you're thinking about
something you envision something like
that place you know
i i have had quite a few patients that
and i tell them this i'm like hey you
know
they a lot of them tend to feel pretty
quiet like they have like um
all the the mental movie is sort of
taking a break when they're when they're
done for their session for the day and
they kind of like
i'm like yeah just roll with that don't
do any homework just sort of like
try to you know i try to keep them on
zero um
and i and i say it is you know very
possible that if you just start burst
out into tears later tonight
that's normal yeah that means like
you're you've connected to something
and that's like an overdue release
that's fascinating man
yeah i noticed after a couple of
treatments i'd had an idea i was running
one day and i just had like a good idea
and these have good ideas all the time
i mean i'm just i'm judging my own ideas
but i thought they were pretty good but
but i used to have ideas a lot
and i just for like a year i just hadn't
even gotten an idea
like i've just been kind of living with
the pieces of every day you know
and it's been fine life has been fine
i'm not i'm not complaining i'm not
asking for any pity i'm just explaining
where i'm at but
but i hadn't found it got anything new
to come out of my brain
right now and so i noticed that i was
running by some turkeys somewhere at
this park and then
i don't know i just got like an idea
that was like fun and it made me laugh
it made me smile i was like oh man what
a gift like
when something's able to just kind of
travel through us and make us feel good
which is how we probably should be a lot
of times you know yeah is to be a
conduit for
joy to at least pass through right
instead of being kind of a
um a place where something has put up a
fence or something is put up like a
firewall or
you know different elements like you're
saying yeah and that's what i want to
say like i'm not
telling anybody to go get this therapy
or or saying that this is
you know i wanted to have an experience
with it um because i'm going to try to
get off of antidepressants
so i'm working with my doctor now and
try and like
slowly wean myself off um which is some
which is cool the the place that i went
there they have like some follow through
there with like trying to help me like
do that and
and manage that so i'm excited about
that and i'm still working with my
regular therapist
but yeah i definitely wanted to have the
experience just so i knew kind of what
it was like
and what's possible you know i love to
kind of figure out how i'm thinking and
feeling and why
and stuff like that you know
so it's it's nice to kind of see if what
things i can get
get through and get away from and i i
find that like anchors i can pull up
kind of i find that you know in
in my practice about half of my patients
don't get ketamine
like we we you know it's sort of like
why are you here
and they're more like they don't know
why they're there they're like
they want access to well-being they want
relief from distress that's what they
really want
right but they come in with like
diagnoses and i'm like well let's talk
about what you
what's really going on and then you know
we we talk and
we we gotta you know it's like we gotta
get to know each other it's not like i'm
like hey yeah here get out
um and they may turn into ketamine
patients once we find like hard stops
places that are are you know
like i shared earlier i had the lady
she wasn't a ketamine patient okay
and as we got to know each other and i
was sort of helping shaper therapy
using other things we she felt
comfortable sharing me
with some pretty disturbing stuff and
then she shared
some even more disturb and then she she
couldn't she stopped
i was like um
yeah it's sort of like let's let's
change gears
because we're running into some very
emotionally distressing things that she
couldn't articulate at that point
and in order to get through those we i
wanted to protect her
so that's when we slid over into the the
ketamine room
and now she's she's about she's in
process and she's
all you can just see the light in her
eyes now she's
you know it's like she it's like it's
not just like go get ketamine it's like
why are you here
right and and
that's why we we talk about what's going
on
and well there was an experience one mo
i had an experience at one point where i
felt like i ended up like in a corner of
the world kind of
it was kind of like i felt like you ever
been in like a video game and you get
stuck somewhere on it you can't even
move like your
guy gets stuck i felt like i got stuck
at like the edge of the
universe like where the universe like we
like i finally found like the two walls
of the universe like the ends of it
and i got stuck like in the corner
and i don't know what was going on were
you leaving the chair or coming back to
the chair i was on my way back to the
chair
okay yeah it's interesting like
you know because like did you feel like
you were like getting light in the chair
and then like your fingers started to
get all yeah you know i don't even
notice that i just remember
kind of talking in a conversation and
then next you know i go on this ride
and i'm not even talking that much
anymore i'm just kind of on this journey
people are so i i talk to my patients a
lot and they
some of them remember some of them don't
but
um they come in different they come in
different like
personalities like you can kind of
there's i'm starting to get a
there's different types that come in
there like i got my musicians
and they start singing for me and uh you
know they're belting it out or they're
composing
right there in front of me and i'm like
this is cool and then you know you got
the guys who might my trees are running
off the screen
and my one kid who tried to hop up and
run out but he forgot he was on ketamine
you can't move
he didn't even get out of the chair you
could just see it he was like and i was
like
it's okay man and uh that's crisped out
man he's probably all crisped out
yeah he he added some issues it gets i
mean it's definitely
gnarly i was i i didn't feel like i
guess in some ways it felt like a drug
it felt like an experience to me right
you know um i felt like i was kind of
grateful for the experience i was
grateful to be back from the experience
whenever i got back from the like trip
or whatever you kind of go on during it
or whatever like
the visual the experience the
out-of-body kind of experience i felt
grateful whenever i got back to my chair
because there was moments where i was
like i am never
you know i don't care yeah they'll
i'll never they'll never find me yeah
it's like i'm lost like where am i
in the world in the universe that will
never find me i was at like i was in
atlanta i was in castlevania that video
game for when i was a kid
i was in some i was on the back of
someone's
neck i was a there was a lot it was i
was sliding down stuff a lot of like
moving along huge
i don't know if it was like electronic
land sides of walls
i don't know i had a lady recently she
could hear
um i got like these pictures of a forest
or
in my one of my rooms and she could hear
the forest
wow and then she was like then she'd
hear a lot more like
and i was like that's pretty cool you
know because she it was she was not
disturbed she was just like oh yeah i
can hear the forest
and i was like that was a first like the
auditoriums were
were are not as common that's strong
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another
and you can watch this one you can watch
this one different options different
choices
some guy just brings you one option not
this guy
two options watch one this one or this
one